oh there you go yeah I just I just went
I just dropped in
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Lenny Kravitz he's
a four-time Grammy award-winning
singer-songwriter and one of the seminal
rock artists of a generation selling
more than 40 million records worldwide
over the course of his storied music
career you can also catch him starting
alongside Jennifer Lopez in the new film
shotgun wedding which is now available
on Prime video Lenny Kravitz welcome to
the show how you doing man I'm doing
good and you know why I'm doing good
tell me it's a historical day in hot
ones history the first time that we've
ever bridged the generational divide
with our guests your daughter Zoe
Kravitz did hot ones almost three years
ago to the day with ease I might add
what's going through your mind as you
prepare to take on The Gauntlet did you
by chance reach out to her for any tips
I watched her episode you know I I had
to study it I'm hoping that since we
come from the same you know
that uh
it's gonna be all right
over here yep
what are these
[Music]
that's some weird uh fake chicken
laughs
[Music]
that's good there we go yeah light
little uh fruitiness it could be some
confidence going in you know I can
handle this but I know that there's a
game to this you do that on purpose the
other shoe waiting for it to drop right
so your latest project shotgun wedding
tells the story of a picturesque wedding
ceremony that gets taken over by Pirates
and they turn this picturesque ceremony
into a full-blown hostage crisis and
your role is a pretty physical one from
the fight scenes to the shootouts to the
high stakes parasailing and playing Sean
what did you find to be the most
challenging thing and what was most
rewarding
uh the most challenging thing definitely
was the with the stunts
uh I've never done stunts before and
um they had an amazing stunt team you
know guys that worked on uh James Bond
actually the Batman as well so I had to
learn fight routines do these routines
up in the parachute on water on the
boats but it was fun we had a great team
it was very safe and uh very well
organized
[Music]
what's on top
it's kind of like a ranch inspired sauce
and then you get like a little tahini in
there so unique flavor and unique color
here for our lineup
I'm waiting yep that's a smart man right
there smart man
of all the guitars that you own is there
one that you describe as your Holy Grail
either because of the backstory that it
has or your sentimental attachment to it
there's a guitar that Robert Plant gave
me at the end of our tour uh during my
Are You Gonna Go My Way tour in 93 94.
uh Robert Plant opened for me which
makes absolutely no sense whatsoever but
he had a new solo record and he wanted
to go out and play for the younger
generation and he gave me a beautiful
Les Paul junior
that he signed well he didn't sign it
but he gave me uh this case they had a a
brass plaque on it and it said to Lenny
thanks for the ride Robert
it's very special to me oh yeah and then
off the top of your head without
thinking about it too much which song
has the best guitar lick
ever ever wow that's uh
there's a lot but I would say that
Purple Haze Jimi Hendrix is
is quite strong and really quite
original
[Music]
nice little kick
I feel this is like
first time we take kind of a step up you
know
she's hot yep yeah
she's hot here we go here we go
so back in 2003 you founded a design
firm Kravitz designed in part because
you couldn't find furniture to fit your
aesthetic so decided to start making it
yourself who makes the best coffee
tables like is there someone that you
look at as like the Zeppelin of coffee
tables I'm actually in the market for
example of coffee tables there's a lot
there's an amazing woman by the name of
Gabriella crespi a gentleman by the name
of Willie Rizzo
uh Paul Evans these are some of my
favorite uh designers that make really
beautiful
sexy coffee tables that are art
essentially all right one's gotta go
design Edition all right so you gotta
cross one off one's gotta go mid-century
modern Bohemian or farmhouse
The Farmhouse I have to go then
Farmhouse if you're making me get rid of
something but you'll love them all
absolutely there's there's a place for
everything just like the wings so far
all hitting all working for you are you
ready to move on to Sauce number four
this is the Los Calientes Verde here in
the four spot
Los Calientes
[Music]
nice flavor
I like that
and it's and the heat is smooth
love to hear that smooth finish yeah do
you have a favorite sauce so far
um that's one of them actually yeah
we'll take that we'll take that and the
first one was nice if you want something
very simple but nice flavor
so you have a unique perspective having
grown up in New York at the birth of
hip-hop what do you remember about the
first time that you encountered it and
what was your initial reaction
the first time I encountered hip-hop was
on my block in Bed Stuy on
Kosciuszko Street
one of our neighbors was in his front
yard with two turntables homemade
speakers I didn't quite understand what
was happening because he was talking
about making music but I was like you're
playing records then it happened you
know it all clicked and I understood
but it but it was really beautiful to
before it was on the radio before it
became commercial to see it on the Block
in the street with my neighbors yeah
well at Ground Zero being in bed style
yeah
so you have the Bronx you have Brooklyn
you know and so I got the Brooklyn side
of it another MC in the goat
conversation that you're closely
associated with is Jay-Z what would you
say distinguishes his style in the
studio
every time I've worked in them and I
know that this is the way he works in
general is there's there's no pen and
paper
he listens to the track you know you put
it on you blast the track and he sits
there at the console puts his head down
Play it Again Play it again maybe two or
three times and then goes in and just
gives you perfection
it's really uh beautiful to watch
oh Brooklyn okay
that's a nice flavor too yeah kind of
has like um
he sneaks up on you though
it's good whoa
you like that yeah and as you said it I
felt like you ever catch a flake
you know oh yeah inhale oh yeah and just
finds a spot because in the Bahamas we
do a lot of uh like for instance we have
this this dish called boiled fish which
is something that's very popular uh for
breakfast especially after a night out
partying and basically it's this uh fish
grouper and they boil it in it's water
onions herbs and different things and
they cut the peppers that go in it so we
have these Peppers called bird peppers
and uh basically you just take it and
you use your knife or your spoon and you
just keep scraping on the side of the
bowl
you put it in there and then you have
those pieces that are can come loose
pretty hardcore yeah
all right like rabbits we have every
crane segment on our show called explain
that gram we're doing deep dive on our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
show you the picture over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
how did the music of James Brown enter
your life and what do you remember about
meeting them for the first time so that
was at the VH1 fashion Awards we did
Papa's Got a Brand New Bag together and
it was really wonderful because he
he knew me but he didn't know me so
we did this tune and he liked what I was
doing and we were done uh he said you
know if you if you keep doing this you
know you you you're gonna get somewhere
you know and it was but it was really
pure and really beautiful
but the first time I saw him play Live
was when I was about six or seven years
old at the Apollo Theater I still
remember I still remember the way it
felt the smells the colors everything
was deep purples and and and and Maroons
and dark greens it was just like really
beautiful and then you have like one of
those like original Godfather of Soul
like suits right how do you know that
I do yeah there's uh there's a jumpsuit
a denim jumpsuit and that was from The
Rumble in the Jungle with sort of black
stretchy material here
but James was wearing that outfit and um
I got it at auction after James passed
can you give us a trade secret when it
comes to the art of the Super Bowl
halftime shows like in what ways is it a
uniquely singular experience for a
performer well actually they made me
change my shirt uh
right before we were going out I was
already in the tunnel lined up getting
ready to go out and
they made me change my shirt why they
want you to change your shirt well
actually they made me put on a shirt
I just I just had on the jacket the
leather jacket that you see there
I don't know maybe that you know they
didn't want the bear chest they don't
play with they seems yeah they don't
play with the nipples they don't play
with the nipples in the halftime show
all right one more for you
as an avid photographer is there a
collection or a single photo you're most
proud to have taken
I was very close with a gentleman by the
name of Herman Leonard who happens to be
the grandfather of Zoe's friend Skye who
was at the shoot yes you remember yeah
yeah you brought her on afterwards so
Herman Leonard was a master photographer
who shot the Jazz world
pictures of Dexter Gordon with the sacks
with all the smoke around Billie Holiday
Duke Ellington so forth and he came down
and hung out with his family
and I took
the last portrait of him
uh which is
very special to me and was a a great
honor and he was just a beautiful
beautiful human being
[Music]
mushroom
what's the mushroom part there's like
there's mushrooms in it got some
Portobello Portobello's in there
oh there you go
I just I just went
I just dropped in the mushroom Mayhem
you know
is there an album of yours or even a
single song that you'd say went through
the biggest Evolution from what it
started as What It ultimately ended up
becoming
um
there's always those couple of songs per
record that don't happen as quickly as
the others and take time because I'm
very much into also the art of recording
so the tune might be right but I don't
like the sound of the snare drum or I
don't like the sound of the bass or
I want to try a different microphone on
that vocal
um on the Are You Gonna Go My Way album
there's a track called believe that just
kept going and going and going and I
kept re-recording
different instruments and and all but uh
everything might work and one thing then
goes on top that doesn't and then it
tears the whole house down below you so
you have to figure out which elements
you want to keep and what you want to
replace and that
that's a whole dance
you know
puzzle on a sculpture
at the same time that's what it is
crafting creating making music
so this next one
is the dream of calypso
the dream of calypso it's a angry goats
dreams of calypso do you like that name
it seems like you'd like that name
whoo
[Music]
where's that from
it's actually from Vermont dreams of
clips and dreams of Calypso from Vermont
[Music]
yeah
wow different level yeah that's that's
some Dragon [__] right yeah fire we're
flying we're good now
yeah this one Mellows after it after it
Peaks it Mellows down yeah it makes a
lot of noise up front yeah but it
doesn't do that thing where it's kind of
just continues to build on you but it
okay there it goes yeah
there it goes to the front of the tongue
now just when you think you have it
figured out you know yeah
what do you think you learned going to
music clubs like the Odyssey like how do
you think that kind of like shaped your
attitude as a rock star that was a
really cool place that I used to sneak
out at night and go there and come back
home like five in the morning and then
go to school
um this is like dirty like stealing my
parents car yeah which was it was which
was a whole operation stealing that car
um because I had to I had to enter my
parents room
crawl on the carpet
to the side of my parents bed on my
dad's side there was this little closet
I had to get in that closet and then I
had to
feel on all the different shelves get
the keys close the door get back down on
my hands and knees crawl back out and go
that took about literally 20 minutes to
steal the keys
and then I would have to uh
put the car in reverse and push and it
was the whole thing yeah yeah I wanted
to go to the Odyssey and hang out and it
was incredible it was a new wave new
Romantics music fashion and uh
yeah that was kind of like a home for me
for for a while
[Music]
so this next one is the bomb Beyond
insanity
you know sometimes I'm caught in sort of
an ethical tug of war like should I warn
guests about this should I not right
oh it's hot immediately
nothing fun about it either like
remember I'm the last sauce like oh it's
hot right but you're like oh but I kind
of like it very delicious
this there's nothing fun no
hot on the throat yeah
[Music]
damn yeah
I know it doesn't stop nah but that's
gonna dive in the taste
what I got
oh so this is from you
I don't drink milk so and I don't like
fake milk I don't like anything trying
to be meal right right no imitation of
milk
as a kid it's from natural lemonade over
here
foreign
that one's just nasty yeah that's not
even like
for food you know what I mean no no it's
just to [__] with people no
yeah exactly it's just for this moment
in the show
wow this audience right
but keeping your cool I have to say not
that I should you know expect anything
else but I'm Zoe's dad
[Music]
yeah that's some hot sauce you're gonna
tell me you're talking like that
no but I mean I don't know it's just uh
it's like a cross that I bear at this
point you know like even Zoe when she
did three years ago she went in on this
one too you know it just stays here you
have found your Niche bro at this point
I could probably get the sauce off the
table but I choose to keep it here
because of this like for this right so
when you say like do you enjoy it no but
for whatever reason it does have to stay
here you know what I mean I don't know
how to I don't know how to pass those
things
do you have a Mount Rushmore of tropical
fruits
tropical fruits yeah
[Laughter]
uh I like you man
um
coconut there we go I drink coconut
water every day and eat coconut uh off
my trees uh
soursop mmm would you would you grow
outside the trailer which is really
really healthy and delicious uh sugar
apples which they're not apples it's a
it's a Caribbean fruit
um guavas mangoes
that's that's it
that's my favorite
bro you know what I'm doing good if
you're doing good you know what I mean
I'm fine sometimes I feel like I'm a
North star for the guests now Lenny
Kravitz I'm following now but your eyes
are all watery yeah I'm following okay
you know
if you're ready to move on to the next
one I am
damn okay
thank you
okay what does that mean these are these
are for tacos
tacos from hell
um
[Music]
I gotta go to Premiere after this
very brave
so like most cool people you've had the
label thrust upon you without using it
to ever describe yourself do you think
that there's anything that you did as a
dad to embarrass Zoe as a kid because
you know it is kind of funny to think
about like kids groaning at like a rock
star parent But ultimately that has to
be a universal experience for everybody
I think like
still continue to embarrass her
um
you know it's a
when she was young you know and and I
had to pick her up from school and
things like that
some of the clothes that I wore I don't
think she was uh too happy with that you
know
I think she would like me to blend in a
little more you know
all right Lenny Kravitz what's this
oh what happens now
[Music]
so this is the last app we call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra on the last
Wing you don't have to what if you don't
want to extra you don't have to if you
don't want to as though that wasn't
enough
all right let's see let's put a little
taste just a little bit
yeah rub it in yup all right
we're doing this cheers lady all right
my brother what a ride
[Music]
and wings up and ten Wings down Lenny
Kravitz and to close things up you're a
musician whose music fuses everything
from r b pop Funk Jazz but at the end of
the day you really are like an
ax-wielding rock star in its truest form
so to close things out I'm curious are
you more optimistic or less optimistic
about the next great Rock Renaissance
more optimistic because there's so many
kids learning to play guitar bass drums
keyboards horns instruments you know all
these kids coming up and they're playing
and they really appreciate
the music that came before them and uh
so I think in the in the years to come
it will explode again
well a standing ovation for Lenny
Kravitz look at you coming in here
taking on the wings of death doing Zoe
proud the first father daughter Duo to
ever take on the hot ones Gauntlet 20
wings up 20 wings down and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
what I have going on in my life uh we
have shotgun wedding which is gonna
start streaming on the 27th of January
uh I've got three albums in the can
we're gonna start releasing music uh
mid-year and I'll be back
for World Tour starting at the end of
the year
[Applause]
thank you brother thank you
that's the hot ones experience that's
great
did you have a good time yeah man that
was awesome it was just the bomb but
that's not even it's just it's just you
feel it on your mouth that's all
that was good and now you're ready to go
to this Premiere you're gonna have a pep
in the step absolutely that's great
thank you for having me thank you I
really appreciate it
damn
hot ones fans breaking news the three
and one boneless bites challenge is back
for a limited time you can put your
taste buds to the test against some of
our most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three in one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit
hotoneschallenge.com for more
information on products and to find a
store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home foreign